how many here liked dishonored how many
people that's watching this video
enjoyed those type of games if you
enjoyed dishonored one and two and maybe
even pray it wasn't the greatest game
for me but i know a lot of people liked
it i might have a game for you it's
called death loop it's on the
playstation 5 and this video is going to
be reviewing it but before we get on
with the video definitely hit that like
button if you guys enjoyed the review
you can always subscribe to the channel
for weekly content and don't forget to
go there and follow me at twitter
lordaddictiop and without any further
ado let's review
death loot for the playstation 5.
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming out here
coming at you for another video today
we're going to be reviewing def loot for
the playstation 5 ironically made by a
microsoft studio yes that's right you
heard me correctly this is one of those
studios that microsoft bought that was
currently working on a playstation 5
exclusive and they honored that
agreement so this is a playstation 5
exclusive most likely going to come out
for the xbox next year but right now
we're going to be reviewing the
playstation 5 version as of launch as of
right now first thing we're going to
talk about is we're talking about the
story of death luke it's a typical
arcade game now that doesn't really
necessarily mean anything positive or
anything negative i've always felt like
arcade games make average stories
nothing fantastic like such as like the
last of us or they don't make anything
like really really bad they make very
passable stories and i don't think their
games highlight the stories i think for
the most part arcade games highlight the
gameplay they highlight how you play the
game and they highlight really the
decisions you make in those games and
the story is always what complimented
that gameplay it always was the driving
factor to why you would play an arcade
game is to use that gameplay to find out
what story they're telling i don't
necessarily think it's the other way
around i do feel like there's a lot of
games out there that you know the story
is so good it doesn't really matter what
that game plays like because you're
really intrigued on what's going to
happen next i feel like when it comes to
arcane death loop in particular it's
pretty much the other way around the
gameplay is so good that it really wants
you to learn more of the story and use
that gameplay to complete that story now
let's talk about a little bit about
gameplay what i was talking about
earlier this game is you know probably
right on par with dishonored in terms of
how the gameplay is you know you can
play from your typical assassination
type to the typical stealth type you can
go on their guns blazing if you want it
does
honor that type of gameplay that arcade
games have had in the past arcane arcade
arcane we're gonna go with arcane i know
you guys are gonna correct me in the
comment section and that's perfectly
fine but the way that their games
generally play is you can play it how
you want to you can upgrade your
abilities to play the way that that play
and that style that you want to play for
instance if you want to go in there and
stealth like you're probably going to
pick more stealth like mechanics in the
game such as blink what's called
shifting here and you're going to pick
more abilities maybe even you want to go
invisible because that is an option in
this game now if you want to go the
typical way that uh some shooters would
go you go more brute force you go like
telekinesis or you know just in
generally making shields around yourself
there's a lot of options in terms of how
you want to play this game now the
biggest criticism i can give about the
gameplay in death loop is i felt like
they played it a little bit too safe i
felt like arcane
played more on dishonor than trying
anything new and i get it you made a
successful franchise and you know a lot
of people like prayed not myself
including but when it comes to the
dishonored franchises you have a good
following when it comes to those type of
games dishonored 1 sold very well and
dishonored 2 didn't sell as much but i'm
pretty sure it had its audience so when
it comes to these type of decisions it's
hard to make that decision should i
change the gameplay drastically and kind
of spit on the people who really built
my brand or should i stay faithful to
that type of gameplay to that type of
audience that's really loved my games
and not really
go too much off of that foundation and
innovate too much on that gameplay
because it would upset my loyal fans or
should i go balls to the wall make new
type of gameplay no use nothing that
wasn't dishonored and go ahead and try
to build more of an audience off of
people that might not necessarily have
liked the dishonored games and to be
honest with you guys at the end of the
day i'm always for the loyalties if your
fan base built you to what you are now
and they love that type of gameplay keep
doing it but i do feel like they did it
so much that some of the abilities such
as shift is literally just blinked from
dishonored and i felt like you know do
something a little bit different kind of
like how they did in dishonored 2 with
emily where he wasn't necessarily using
blink he was using a different ability
that had the same effect that blink did
have but it did it differently and i
wanted something a little bit more such
as that a little bit more often but
that's just my opinion on terms of the
gameplay now let's talk a little bit
about the graphics now to me i don't
personally feel like the graphics and
death flute was anything fantastic but
they would look nice they just it wasn't
anything like wow draw you know jaw
dropping moment nothing that really
would stand the loop of time oh that's
funny definitely time we're gonna move
right past that but at the end of the
day i don't necessarily have always put
100 into the graphics i personally feel
like gameplay is the most important
things in terms of games and graphics is
a little bit lower on the list but i
really don't think none of you're going
to be disappointed in the way death loop
looked like some of you obviously you
know with games such as last of us 2 go
sushima maybe compared to those type of
games it is definitely falling short in
terms of what the graphics look like but
in terms of a standalone title and a
brand new ip as death flip i think it
does stand its own ground not
necessarily at the higher list of games
that look graphically demanding but it's
definitely not at the lower end of the
games that look graphically demanding
now in terms of death loop i think it's
a solid foundation for something that
maybe arcane can build on in the future
i do feel like they spit a little bit
too much in terms of trying to be too
much like dishonored and maybe putting
the game in the dishonored universe
would have really helped it in terms of
the fans that enjoy this game i do feel
like there's a lot of incidences in this
game where in arcade games i've always
felt like you have more choices you have
more ways to combat certain scenarios
but in this particular game i do feel
like they kind of put you on one
straight path and they didn't really let
you wander off left or right too too
much i'm not saying there's no choices
whatsoever but in terms of the overall
concept of the game there's not a whole
lot of choices in that matter i do think
death loop is worth the 70 dollars if
you enjoyed those dishonored type games
if you didn't definitely stay away from
it i don't think they did anything
drastically enough to win you over if
you didn't like dishonored one and two
and if you think that this game's gonna
be drastically better than dishonored
one and two i don't really think that
either i think it's about on the same
par maybe a little bit lower i'm not
necessarily saying that it's exactly
where dishonored 1 2 is but i do think
in terms of the quality of the product
it is around that same level and that's
pretty much the review of death loop i
think it's a solid experience i wouldn't
say it's a defining genre experience i
don't think it really pushed stealth
likes anyway forward it just pretty much
put exactly what you would expect from
an arcade game in terms of dishonored i
don't think they did anything
drastically different in terms of what
this honor was
and for the most part everything they've
done in the game has been done in
another game i just feel like in terms
of this game death loop's not a console
seller but i do think if you do have a
playstation 5 or you have a good enough
pc and you can get this on sale
definitely pick it up and if you like
the dishonored games maybe it's worth
that 70 dollars to you or you can just
do what a lot of people i assume on the
xbox platform are probably going to do
is wait for this to get in game pass
because i do think this is a solid
experience to go into a service like
game pass so if you want to wait for the
xbox version i totally understand
because it's like i said this game
didn't do anything drastically different
than anything you've played before i
just felt like it was a great experience
and i definitely recommend it but anyway
tell me what you guys think about death
loop and down there in the comment
section below if it's something that you
are kind of interested in but you don't
really have a whole lot of concept of
what this game's about put it in the
comments section below and until next
time this is gaming addict i'm out of
here peace